what do those 12 hours entail that
you're in front of that computer
what what are you starting your day off
with what are you doing what do you wake
up do you get two emails first what's
your thumb I need to do push-ups first I
need to so I force myself before I can
have coffee I got to do 150 Diamond
push-ups then I can sit down because if
I don't do that if I just sit down in
front of the computer that's it it's
done
then I'll sit down with the coffee
essentially emails first oh my god the
emails do you get too many emails yeah
how can we reverse this it's horrible
but there were some important ones in
discerning surgeon so do them then I got
about 14 social media sites that I'm on
so I got to go to each one of them and
do whatever has it's just the daily
maintenance a new post I try to have a
message of the day that cuts across all
social media I try to make it include a
link then I'll do a Google search on
myself
I've got Google searches for about 15
variations on me Gulliver's ugly
Gulliver skin Gulliver's creepy
the lovers actor blah blah blah blah
blah you find all kinds of links from
all over the world because foreign sites
pick up stuff up high and medium put it
on can i exploit those links is there
some way I can work this what's the
angle so then by about 10 o'clock in the
morning I've got a list of about seven
different avenues of things that could
be the message of the day and by noon I
need to have that message to find had
the link and start spreading it across
all the media so then I do that then I
go back to email and then just lather
rinse repeat and in the in the middle of
that every day I try to do three or four
cold contacts with directors of
producers and more so producers because
a producer told me a year ago and it
really hit me he said nobody respects us
nobody ever contacts us nobody gives us
the credit that we sue us for helping to
make this picture possible so when I see
a project I'm interested in I write to
the producers first and if they can get
excited about me they will contact the
director and then in between all of that
you know there's the standard
submissions that you do and the standard
auditions
and then you look up and it's time for
beheading and you haven't left the house
do you rest on your manager or agent
finding you work or you know also no
absolutely not and every younger actor
who's asked me number one I said what
the hell do I know you know I'm trying
to make it myself I'm just another
working actor but if you want advice
forget you have an agent forget you have
a manager find your own work if they
find your work it's gravy but until you
to the level where you don't really need
them they're not gonna be able to help
you nobody's gonna take you under their
wing and care about you and make your
career you do that yourself if you're
not willing to do it come on this is a
very brutal town and it has no there's
no spot here for people who want to be
coddled
maybe I'm teaching them no I agree so
how do we stay safe in our minds how do
we deal with the fact that it is a very
very tough town and and not lose our
sanity basically and not become hardened
and bitter this is why of the hundreds
of thousands of actors who are in LA you
see the same ones at auditions over and
over again and I know this is true for
you to carry right you see you see the
same people it's because there's a very
small pool of people who can do this
it's a heartbreaking business it's full
of rejection people say oh you know
should I come to a light no don't unless
you feel that you must like there's a
preacher when I was a kid and I remember
asking him you know why you preach he's
a boy preaching ran after me and I ran
from it but it caught me so I preached
and I think that's it if you have the
passion for it that you can't do
anything else with your life and be
happy then you can probably make it but
you just want to be famous
good luck
you